threats to law enforcement have exploded  after the fbi executed a search warrant  at donald trump's mar-a-lago estate this  shouldn't come as a surprise to us they  claim to back the blue they claim to be  all about funding the police the thin  blue line all of these things  and yet  now that it was indeed federal law  enforcement that conducted this uh  search warrant  at donald trump's estate  now they're saying defund the fbi  and the doj  and they are actually showing up look at  what happened at the fbi's field office  in cincinnati  look at what happened in washington d.c  these people are willing to do violence  and they're very dangerous